our next guest I'm very excited about
this one one of the stars of the hit TV
show manifest Netflix has just released
the final episodes this is a show about
a group of airline passengers who vanish
when their plane suddenly disappears
mid-flight and then five years later the
aircraft and its passengers reappear but
for those on board no time has passed
and they are exactly the same age as
before actor Luna Blaze plays olive
stone Olive was not on the missing
flight but her family was including her
twin brother cow in this clip Olive and
Cal reflect on the time they have lost
take a look
I wish I could have grown up with you
plane disappeared
it felt like
my kid took both of our childhoods with
it
I missed you
so much
I knew I just felt it
that you were
that you were still alive
we may have lost time
but we never lost each other you seen
this before
only on CBS morning's Luna Blaze joins
us now Luna good morning good morning
thank you very much
all right you were 16 when it first
started uh now you're 21. yeah now the
final episodes are out people can watch
the whole thing what's it like to
confront this moment of it's in the
world and there will be no more it's
it's honestly it's truly a blessing I
mean the fact that I can say that I'm 21
and I've just finished you know a
five-year run of a show has been it's
been the best blessing that I could
honestly ever even imagine and it's been
so fun you know I I moved to New York
when I was 16 for this job that I didn't
know what was going to happen with I had
no idea where I was going or what and it
was really awesome to like see myself as
like a young woman just like flourish
like in New York and on this show and
you know now that it's over I get to you
know step onto this new chapter and it's
it's really fun and Luna you were still
flourishing can we say I mean number one
the show is on another Network they
didn't pick it up Netflix stepped in so
that shows fan validation this past
weekend when it dropped it's now number
one trending on Netflix what does that
mean to you and I'm wondering if you're
satisfied with how it ended because it
was it's open to interpretation but in a
good way I thought yeah it's
you know honestly I think that
with the opportunity that Netflix gave
us with with now like two years ago at
this point where they were you know
willing to pick up our show for 20
episodes is first of all just crazy and
the fact that they gave us that
opportunity for our incredible
showrunner Jeff Frick and all our
amazing writers to finish our story it
felt like we got cut off on a certain
point that no one really no one wanted
to end there right and even we we were
just like this isn't the end this can't
be the end like there's no way and so
for Netflix to come to us and be like
you know what we're giving you this
platform to finish your story do it
right basically I think we did right by
that and it was special because your mom
was on the set I love a girl who's close
to her mother your mom showed up to
surprise you tell us what that that
whole experience was like for you as it
was ending you know it was really crazy
I it was nuts just thinking okay that
the show's ending it's that's gonna be
that like we're all gonna be good I'm
gonna finish they're gonna finish wipe
our hands clean but it was very
emotional it was it was it was heavier
on me than I thought it would be because
genuinely like you know like you said
it's just I grew up on this show and the
last day that I I filmed was actually
the last day of production so it was
everyone's last day and it was that last
phone call scene
um so you know they were like and that's
a series wrap on Luna and then my mom
comes out and I was like no no no no no
there's no way and like she lives in L.A
so it was just like so surreal and crazy
and just you know in front of me was
everyone that I'd been with for five
years yeah I'll keep the compliments
going you were incredible thank you
um and your your character was
very layered and you mentioned the word
complex I feel like the script is that
it's complex but it's easy to follow
yeah and then there's this confusion
that that leads to this curiosity that
we all have and we're curious to know if
there's going to be a spin-off so we we
heard that there's some Whispers
um it could be something would you be
interesting Luna's not looking at you
Nate like I don't speak English right
there is room I think there is room for
imagination I think that definitely you
know in the I feel like this manifest
World it just it can't just be the stone
family and the people that were
surrounded by them I think that I mean
for me I would love to see a Vance
spin-off I think that would be awesome I
think the ripple effect is there the
ripple effect is there there is so much
room for imagination the Manifest world
I feel like it can grow but I also feel
like it could end that it I'm there's no
I'm not saying anything over here let me
just tell you the name Luna Blaze I was
running is that the name on your birth
certificate because I was thinking no
offense to you or your mother I thought
it's either a great stripper name or
it's a great athlete name it is the name
it is the name have you ever been told
that before wow
it is on the birth certificate where it
is the Luna Blaze Boyd it is right there
everyone says it to me they're they're
like it is it real is it not real no I
love it
now watch manifest right now on Netflix